[Music]
for well over a decade the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has brought the comic
world to the big screen using
state-of-the-art visual effects and
elaborate stunts making a marvel movie
is physically demanding work for the
actors and the people behind the cameras
to learn how these movies come to life
let's take a look at what eight Marvel
movies look like behind the scenes the
third Captain America movie went big it
was the first film ever to employ IMAX
2d cameras which came in handy during
the now legendary airport battle for one
daring jump a stunt performer attached
to a rope leaped right behind Bucky to
capture this shot for another shot
they actually flipped a truck over the
sequence were cap faces off against
crossbones and falls out of a window and
then onto an awning a truck and then
finally the ground took a lot of
planning stunt coordinator Sam Hargrave
who also doubled for cap at times said
pulling this off involved constructing
an awning and shipping dock for the
existing building the awning had to be
built at just the right angle and all
the pads had to be obscured
dr. strange took the MCU visually to a
new level the multiverse involves
intense CGI work frame store alone
worked on 365 visual effect shots for
the film so naturally there was a lot of
green screen and empty spaces on set
like when dr. strange walks through this
portal into another dimension on set he
was really walking through what looked
like a giant glowing hula hoop meanwhile
elaborate wire work was used to give the
appearance the characters were floating
through the air and when strange takes
on his astral form the visual effects
team backlit everything this helped them
more easily create a transparent effect
and what about Strange's fateful car
crash according to director scott
derrickson they had to destroy about
nine real Lamborghinis for this one
scene unsurprisingly outer space in the
sequel to guardians of the galaxy looked
a lot like a blue screen one of the most
subtle touches in the film was the D
aging done to Kurt Russell for the
opening flashback well they did do some
makeup touch-ups to make him look
younger it was largely CGI a young actor
was used for reference of 30 year old
skin and stood in for Russell onset
visual effects artist later grafted some
of the stand-ins skin onto the older
actor and how do you act alongside a CGI
character like baby Groot with this baby
Groot tall which gave the cast a better
idea of how they should make eye contact
with baby grew in a given scene actors
Bradley Cooper and Vin Diesel recorded
the voices of rocket and baby grew in a
sound booth their facial expressions and
gestures were also recorded and used for
reference when animating the characters
in black panther the cast rigorous
training and fighting styles ranging
from judo to jiu-jitsu is unfolded later
Michael B Jordan was covered in about
3,000 prosthetic dots each one was made
with a glue-like material the makeup
team had to make sure they wouldn't all
come off during the warrior fall
sequence given that it was a fight scene
involving a lot of body contact and
splashing water black panther was shot
all over the world many of the Wakanda
scenes were filmed on a soundstage in
Atlanta while the car chase through the
streets of Busan was actually filmed in
South Korea according to cinematographer
Rachel Morrison they wanted to
distinguish Wakanda visually from the
rest of the world one way they did that
lighting for the Wakanda scenes Morrison
said they were lied on warm afternoon
light and use supplemental light to get
rid of any shadows Avengers infinity war
contains approximately 2,900 visual
effect shots Thanos is a motion capture
marvel bringing a CGI character with
over 40 minutes of screen time to life
was a big challenge at times actor Josh
Brolin would wear a Thanos head on top
of his own head so the actors could use
this eye line as a guide Brolin wore a
motion capture suit tracking marks on
his face and a helmet with cameras
attached to it to get every subtle
mannerism
in this sequel Scott Lang fought
alongside hope Van Dyne aka the wasp
she made a big impression early on
during this fight sequence in a
restaurant the stunt team went through
four to five weeks of intense training
for it
Evangeline Lilly worked with them to
tweak the character's moves to fit the
actresses own movements for example
Lilly thought to add a lot of s-curves
into her fighting style giant-man was of
course created with CGI but for the part
where he collapses into the water
they had sprinklers on set to actually
splash on lookers then there is the
stunning quantum realm when building
this microscopic world the visual
effects team made sure to give it a
psychedelic feel everything in this
environment was constantly in motion to
make such a tiny world seem so much
bigger they were lied heavily on macro
photography
other photography devices such as lens
flares added to the energetic visuals
Oscar winner brie Larson got in
superhero shape to portray the titular
hero Larson worked with celebrity
trainer Jason Walsh for nine months
before Captain Marvel started shooting
by the end of their time together she
was strong enough to be able to push a
Jeep so she was more than ready for
shots like this and how do you make
Captain Marvel fly sometimes they used
wires other times they use the tuning
fork rig which is operated by crew
members and blue suits who would be
edited out later Captain Marvel also
features some of the MCU s most
convincing D aging work to date the
visual effects team was tasked with
making Samuel Jackson look like his 1990
self Nick Fury has a lot of screen time
there are at least 800 d aging shots in
the film and the artist had to take
nearly three decades off of him while
filming Jackson donned a wig and
tracking dots on his face in
post-production they got to work
reshaping and re sculpting the actor's
face while altering the texture of his
skin
luckily they had a lot of reference
material of 1990s era Jackson to work
off of
to play the updated version of Thor
chiseled star Chris Hemsworth wore
bodysuit which he estimated weighed 60
to 70 pounds as well as a mouthpiece
that puffed out his cheeks while the
visual effects team did some touch-ups
Marvel Entertainment visual effects
producer Jane underdahl said that
actually having the suit onset helped
Hemsworth's performance and for this one
shot you will notice the actors weren't
actually wearing their nanotech suits on
set that is because it made more sense
to create these suits largely using
visual effects since they constantly
expand and shrink it would be hard to do
that practically nothing compared to the
film's final battle bringing this many
characters together in one place was a
logistical challenge not every actor
could actually be there on set at the
same time take this shot where the emcee
use female heroes stood together Tom
Holland couldn't be there on that day
because Peter Parker hands Captain
Marvel the Infinity Gauntlet they needed
to have somebody there to interact with
brie Larson so another actor stood in
for him and Holland was later digitally
added into the scene thanks for watching
if you like this video subscribe for
more just like it let us know what other
Marvel movies you want to know more
about in the comments
you